at least 20 people have been injured in
a car bomb that exploded in front of the
government building this is in southern
Thailand happened in the city of yalla
where officials were holding a meeting
to discuss the spread of coronavirus
Wayne hey with us now from Bangkok on
skype Wayne take us through what you
know yes well as you mentioned this took
place in yala province in the morning
this is one of the three southernmost
provinces of Thailand bordering Malaysia
and in those three southern provinces
there is an armed Muslim separatist
group operating or several groups
operating they are fighting for
independence or greater autonomy from
Thailand and have been doing so for
years Thailand is of course a
predominantly Buddhist country so these
groups regularly staged attacks in the
three southernmost provinces they are
usually relatively small in nature
usually at gun attacks small bomb
attacks targeting security forces
government buildings as was the case
just a few hours ago and also anyone
that is seemed to be sympathetic to the
government in Bangkok as I say there are
several groups operating in southern
Thailand but there really is in recent
years anyway one main group that is
believed to be behind much of the
violence that is brn Barisan revolution
a tea now or the National Revolutionary
front we believe that it's highly likely
that the brn was behind this bomb attack
outside a government building where
there were several local government
leaders meeting with military officials
as well as you say talking about
coronavirus and how best to tackle this
situation in southern Thailand what
makes this attack particularly
interesting is one of the bombs there
were two bombs outside their building
one of them was a car bomb which is it
does happen in southern Thailand but
they are relatively rare the second
thing is that we seem to have entered a
new round of peace talks beginning in
January the Thai government mess with
leaders of these separatist groups in
Kuala Lumpur they've had two meetings so
far this year what makes those meetings
interesting is that BRM again the group
to be believed to be behind most of the
violence in southern Thailand
was present at the table and the past
and recent peace talks we haven't seen
the key leadership of brn taking part in
those peace talks so there was real hope
that perhaps we were heading down a new
path towards some sort of sustainable
peace a peace rather so it seems perhaps
if this was brn perhaps they are sending
a message that they are not happy so far
with any progress that has or hasn't
been made out of those two rounds of
peace talks thank you for that update
Wayne hey in Bangkok